[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bon livre
dans cette période de rentrée scolaire
tout le monde est bien conscient que la
lecture c'est important pour faire une
bonne scolarité mais plus que ça par
exemple montesquieu dans ses pensées dès
1891 il a souligné l'étude a été pour
moi le souverain romane contre les
dégoûts n'ayant eu de chagrin qu'une
heure des lectures nommé tôt tu es donc
on va lutter contre le chagrin on va
faire une rentrée dans la bonne humeur
avec des passionnés des deux livres qui
vont vous faire partager leur leur bonne
lecture
alors nous commençons avec me monique au
de miniac qui est qui et auteur et
conteuse et les qui fait le lien entre
la france et l'afrique que nous aimons
tellement mais qui va nous parler du
petit prince de centre à dire marmite
aussi l'édition ados marmite qu'être
réputé et qui va nous parler du petit
prince un monument le petit point oui
c'est une grosse responsabilité
donc en fait comme on peut le lire ou de
relire ci et pour sa fraîcheur parce que
l'on soit enfant ou adulte
il ya des réflexions sur la vie c'est
toujours d'actualité ou parle d'amour de
fidélité de la nature des travers des
hommes et ce petit bonhomme et qui nous
fait bien réfléchir et les grandes
personnes qui trouvent qu'elles sont
compliquées et qu'elle mélange toutes
les compagnes hier encore et lui il est
branché sur sa fleur unique au monde et
bernard mardi madier en fait peu la
fleur c'est vrai c'est la phase le faut
que je les remercie de m'avoir donné
cette idée
donc en fait il va il va de 2
de lieux en lieux de planète en planète
il ya la planète du crowd de monsieur
fera moisi qui se prend très très au
sérieux il ya le roi le baobab avec et
pas au bape qui trouvent que
saint-exupéry dessine pas bien les
volcans les le vaniteux le businessman
le réverbère la terre et on arrive à
faire ça vers le serpent avec les
changes avec le serpent qui est très
beau les échos dans la montagne et
surtout le renard l'autre dialogue avec
le renard et à l'aiguilleur ce moment et
j roth j'ai mis toutes les phrases qui
est qui nous frappe
chacune qu'on a entendu qu'est qu'on va
entendre
en fait c'est chacun trouve son étoile
il faut apprivoiser assez d'apprivoiser
jeu c'est de vous apprivoiser créer des
liens lafleur est unique au monde mais
nous mêmes nous sommes uniques au monde
et puis cette image que du show d'uche
et des cheveux d'or tu du petit prince
qui fait penser aux champs de blé et
puis bien sûr l'essentiel est invisible
aux yeux
on ne voit bien qu'avec le coeur voilà
tout ça avec la voix de gérard philipe
si c'est possible
tout ça c'est une merveille un petit
bonheur pour la rentrée je vous souhaite
belle et noble et le petit prince est
connu dans le monde entier
mais si j'étais en corée du sud voir mon
fils ait abusé de la ville du sud-est
il ya une sculpture du petit prince avec
le petit renard qui regardent la mer et
les gens font une files d'attentes pour
être en photo à côté du petit prince et
c'est vraiment il est mondialement connu
comme si moi j'ai connu deux jeunes
filles j'en parlais tout à l'heure qui
font du théâtre qui avait monté le petit
passe et qui sont allés au mali au niger
au burkina faso et qu'ils ont fait
évoluer selon les lieux où s'est
installée voilà vraiment
merci monicault alors comme disait le
petit prince la fin d'une chose marque
commencement d'une autre chose donc
nathalie volts qui est maître de
conférences à l'université de saint
quentin
tout à côté à nous parler de kamel daoud
le livre à bord oui c'est ça merci
bernard je voulais vous parler du livre
aborde de kamel daoud notamment parce
qu'il vient de sortir en poche là et
quelques semaines au mois d'août
juste un petit mot sur game and out
c'est un écrivain nigérian qui vit en
algérie et il est aussi journaliste et
on connaît notamment de lui le fameux
morceau contre-enquête sortie en 2014
qui avait eu le prix goncourt du premier
roman
alors là d'exhaure on va plonger dans un
texte qui n'a rien à voir qui est très
très différents donc on est dans les
pensées du personnage principal
s'appelle ismaël sy l'orphelin de mer en
plus sa mère a été répudiée a quant elle
était vivante
il est rogné par son père et il va vivre
avec sa tante comme un paria dans un
village ça c'est assez ambigu parce
qu'on rejette et en même temps me
respectent et pourquoi il ya cette
ambiguïté parce que il a un pouvoir un
don qu'on lui attribue et d'ailleurs
dont il se persuade lui-même il écrit
pour empêcher les autres de mourir et on
vient le chercher un jour pour qu'il
vienne sauver
justement ce père qu'il a régné avec son
fameux pouvoir donc évidemment dans le
livre des choses magnifiques sur le
rapport au père sur la question de la
colère rentrée sur le fait de pardonner
ou pas d'ailleurs
voilà mais à mon avis
l'essentiel du livre c'est pas ça
l'essentiel du livre c'est un livre sur
le pouvoir d'écrire est alors le dans la
première page du livre on peut lire
écrire et la ciel russes efficace contre
la mort donc là tout est dit c'est
vraiment une allégorie magnifique à
l'écriture à la littérature et c'est
vraiment dans ce livre enfin moi c'est
vraiment ce qui m'a plu c'est la
littérature qui rend libre
la littérature qui libère de tous les
enfermements on est dans un petit
village en algérie qui complètement
enserrée entre le désert et la montagne
et il y à aussi l'enfermement religieux
l'obscurantisme religieux et donc dans
ce livre ismaël qui en fait surnommer
abord savoir ça veut dire les psaumes en
arabe lui il voit le texte comme quelqu
un quelque chose qui sert à interroger
al'inverse de ce que les récitateurs
2005 reste comme ça qui les appelle fond
c'est à dire que eux les obscurantistes
se sert du texte comme un prétexte un
prétexte pour enfermer un prétexte pour
éviter de se questionner et notamment
pour enfermer les femmes il ya la place
des femmes dans les pays en filigrane la
place du corps aussi c'est très très
important et ce que je trouve très
réussie mois dans ce livre c'est qu'en
permanence
il y à l'écriture et le corps l'écriture
et le corps sont indissociables c'est
vraiment quelque chose de charnel il
l'écriture name et charnelle elle est
somptueuse
alors quand même c'est ce qui est fort
c'est que kamel daoud l'a écrit ce livre
dans sa langue qui n'est pas sa langue
maternelle le français et en plus il est
autodidacte dans l'apprentissage du
français
vraiment c'est une langue magnifique
musicale
l'agent dans la pression dieu ah oui il
est tricoté comme journaliste d'abord en
algérie ces chroniques sont très suivi
il a écrit dans le ville écrit dans le
quotidien el watan
le quotidien d'oran pardon et chaque
semaine dont il a ça prenait dans le
point c'est bien le gars sur le monde et
la société
merci nathalie donc clair beldan qui kg
chanteuse de talent et comédienne aussi
qui habite dans la région à montfort
l'amaury va nous parler de rebecca par
daphné du maurier voilà quand on lit
rebecca on n'est pas très étonné que
hitchcock en effet un film
daphné du maurier a inspiré hitchcock
avec trois de ses romans
l'auberge de la jamaïque rebecca est
très connu les oiseaux alors et bkc le
film les oiseaux c'est daphné du maurier
qui qui a écrit le m
c'était en 1963 rebecca c'est l'histoire
d'une jeune femme qui est dame de
compagnie pour une femme difficile
acariâtre et donc elles partent en
voyage à monte carlo dans un hôtel et
dans cet hôtel il y à un homme qui
séjournent également c'est un homme qui
est veuf qui est riche qui est célèbre
et qui est aussi un peu mystérieux madam
devant nous peur celles qui embauchent
là
la dame de compagnie tombe malade elle a
une mauvaise grippe elle doit rester
couché et monsieur de winter invite la
jeune femme à faire des promenades il
invite à déjeuner et au bout de quelques
jours il lui propose de l'épouser elle
accepte partons en voyage de noces en
italie
et puis ensuite qu'ils prennent le
chemin de manderlay manderlay c'est le
domaine en cornouaille les domaines de
monsieur de winter et là les choses
commencent à se compliquer rebecca l'ex
épouse de monsieur de winter bien que
morte est très présente elle a laissé
une empreinte très fortes dans le
domaine auprès des personnes qui
travaillent dans le domaine également et
la jeune épouse a beaucoup de mal à
trouver sa place
elle se sent pas bien et elle se sent de
moins en moins bien elle comprend que
son mari lui cache des choses est de
toute évidence il ya eu un événement à
ne sais pas lequel mais il ya eu s'est
passé quelque chose de malsain quelque
chose de très très pesant et donc on
avance dans le livre le suspense est
grandissant et jusque jusqu'au
dénouement on est vraiment tenu en
haleine
voilà je vous dirai pas la suite donc
voilà ce livre je les lui il ya
plusieurs années je les ai relu pour
l'émission et je pense que je vais
essayer de voir le film pour prolonger
les effets de dix romans et daphné du
maurier c'est une très belle écriture
c'est une très belle écriture les
les paysages on se croirait en
cornouailles en fait c'est il ya
vraiment l'atmosphère qui est présente
c'est c'était très violent le vent aussi
c'est quelque chose de si je peux leur
lit on va abolir et revenir à chaque
fois on trouve quelque chose de nouveau
mais merci clair alors pour terminer
cette édition je veux vous parler de
patrice franceschi qui va venir au salon
du livre d'elancourt à la troisième
édition du salon du livre organisé par
les amis du passé des locaux avec l'aide
du d'elancourt et l'agglo de saint
quentin en yvelines et patrice
franceschi c'est pas n'importe qui il
sera là le dimanche 24 novembre à
elancourt faut pas l'augmenter
le samedi soir il y aura deux films ou
signer cette mère patrie danse esquissés
qui donc c'est là il est enfin
explorateurs marins aviateurs
il a fait deux fois le tour du monde
avec son trois mâts la boudeuse
il a fait le tour du monde en ulm ce
quelque chose de fou il est il et prix
goncourt de la nouvelle 2015 avec
première personne du singulier
il a aussi énormément de aoued écrivains
de marine il fait énormément de choses
et donc israël encourent le les
dimensions 80 et dans ce lille donc
sarpei de nouvelles et il parle il fait
vivre des personnages qui sont des
espèces de don quichotte des gens
passionnés qui cherche la possible
qu'ils sont entiers quoiqu'il ne
l'acceptent pas le compromis et qui
sommeille dans des situations très
difficiles où ils mettent leur vie en
jeu quoi ils ont des choix donc est-ce
que je vais jusqu'à la mort ou pas c'est
vraiment très très fort la première
nouvelle c'est un vieux marin à loups de
mer flaherty un écossais qu'à naviguer
dans toutes les mers du monde et sur son
grand navire un trois mâts et un jour il
lui arrive une tempête terrible
le ma tombe dans l'eau il faut couper
tout sinon mais il ya un gars qui est
sûr le maroc or donc si on coupe le gars
va mourir alors il se pose la question
est-ce que
est-ce qu'on tue une vie pour en sauver
il doit prendre la décision mais ce qui
est terrible c'est que le gars le gars
qui est sur le mât c'est son fils alors
fait vraiment quelque chose comme ça
alors laissez terrible quoi elle et les
autres histoires on a affaire à des
résistants de résistants qui pareille
qui doivent faire le choix entre la vie
et la mort donnée sacrifié leur vie pour
la cause et on a aussi le un sous
lieutenant français pendant la débâcle
de 40 qui a ordre de retarder les
allemands pendant pendant une journée
il se retrouve tout seul et il se tient
sur le poème de victor hugo
si l'on n'est plus que 1000 et bien j'en
suis si même ils ne sont plus que 100 je
brave encore si la cie leurs demeures
10,2 seraient les dizaines et s'il n'en
reste qu'un je serai celui-là ça porte
toute la nouvelle c'est fantastique ça
ne parlons plus
[Musique]